when we think about climate change
mitigation that is the ways in which we
can reduce our carbon footprint we might
consider turning off the lights when we
leave the house riding our bike to work
or driving a fuel-efficient car but most
of us don't think about the food we eat
unfortunately when it comes to
agriculture there's a misconception that
reducing emissions means sacrificing a
farms economic viability but this
needn't be the case when it comes to
climate change mitigation agriculture
provides many opportunities for us to
both reduce our emissions while also
enhancing the profitability and
long-term sustainability of our farms
one of the best examples of this is an
investment in generating on-farm
renewable energy to be clear we are not
talking about growing biofuels for
ethanol but rather direct on-farm energy
production through the use of manure
solar and wind these technologies can
help farms become net zero which means
that the greenhouse gas emissions
produced on the farm are balanced by the
farms efforts to offset or sequester an
equivalent amount of carbon meet don
jensen lon hers farms and chip bailey kc
orchards don is a dairy farmer and chip
and apple grower they both have
different concerns and feelings about
climate change but they share a
commitment to farming for renewable
energy for thousands of years farmers
like dawn and chip have looked for ways
to maximize their resources and improve
the efficiency of their farms in
continuing this tradition both have been
able to take advantage of their existing
on-farm resources to produce energy and
promote the long-term economic viability
of their operations for done this is
meant building an anaerobic digester we
have currently about 1,500 milk cows
1200 supporting lifestyle we found about
2,000 acres in Stanley New York we
produce in
neighborhood of forty million pounds of
milk a year which is marketed locally
through with the Upstate milk
cooperative this is a farm that now has
four generations I'm the third my
daughter and my son will be taking the
business over as time moves on three or
four years ago we were investigating
building an anaerobic digester so
basically an anaerobic digester is a
containment vessel where the inputs
usually manure and sometimes an
additional feedstock like food wastes or
any other organic material is basically
aggregated and it undergoes a
decomposition process it normally stays
in there for on average 20 to 25 days
microbes are constantly breaking it down
and through that process a material
called biogas is created a sixty percent
methane so therefore we can use that as
an input to an electricity generation
unit and generate electricity sort of
like they would with natural gas a farm
is really usually able for a lot of the
year to offset their purchase power
costs from using their own biogas based
electricity on farm the initial reason
we wanted to build a digester was to
create an ample supply of Betty that was
the original reason we just didn't have
enough betting of the solids to bed the
cows and we wanted a pathogen free Betty
the reduction in the odor we are in an
area where there's a fair amount of
housing there's a fair amount of small
little Hamlet's so you know when we're
out there spreading millions of gallons
of
annually we're very sensitive to how the
neighbors feel about it rhinos through
an anaerobic digester doesn't eliminate
eliminate totally but it certainly makes
it more available within the
neighborhood the ability to go out and
put mannar on the fields without a lot
of complaints and a lot of negative
feedback from the community so the in
community friendly is very important to
this this farming operation there's
definitely societal benefits as well
when you get into talking about climate
change reduced methane emissions from
livestock I'd say the most important
role that digesters played in climate
change mitigation is you're
intentionally capturing that methane
that's produced from the livestock
manure and putting that towards a
beneficial use so instead of that
methane which is a very potent
greenhouse gas being released to the
atmosphere you're capturing that and
then once you use that in an engine
generator set to produce electricity you
can reduced purchased fossil fuel-based
power from the grid so that's sort of a
win-win situation so not only has Don
positioned blonde Hurst now and into the
future to take advantage of generating a
renewable electricity resource but also
to the extent that there are revenue
opportunities presented because of the
ecosystem benefits so if in the future
there's a substantial revenue
opportunity from demonstrating carbon
sequestration and carbon management
that's extremely valuable certainly from
the sustainability's of perspective
going forward and the most important
sustainability issues financial
sustainability anaerobic digestion
technology works it's definitely been
proven it's not a new technology what
really is lacking is an economically
favorable environment for these things
to really take off in some of the
feasibility studies that we've done
we've come up with sort of tail and
marketing ideas like a green milk
different farms with digesters or you
know climate mitigation strategies could
put their milk together and claimed that
it was carbon neutral or green that's
definitely a marketing strategy and I
think people pit would pay more just
like they pay more for organic
most dairies are size and frankly
probably a little larger over the next
10 years have got to adopt some sort of
technology we've got a resource within
the waste stream in itself we all we've
got carbon that can be reduced the
carbon footprint what is somewhat of a
new census is now a resource if you have
a digester and frankly we've found that
the amount of time needed to operate
this digester isn't a whole lot more
maybe another half hour a day more than
what we already had invested in handling
on the norm waste anyways this
originally was budgeted to cash flow and
now it's looking at one year of
operation it appears that it's exceeded
our expectations and the digester is one
of the technologies that can can make us
neighbor friendly community friendly and
environment-friendly by proactively
managing his farms waste stream through
the use of a digester Don is lowering
his farms methane emissions while
farming for energy digesters are well
suited for dairy farms but they are not
the only technology available to farmers
for farms without manure solar and wind
production can play a pivotal role in
reducing carbon emissions 35 miles north
of Stanley New York near the shores of
Lake Ontario chip Bailey to is farming
for energy this is my 30th year farming
since graduating from Cornell 1984 and
we have currently about a hundred and
sixty acres in apple production will be
grow about 24 different apple varieties
and we pick on average about a hundred
and sixty-five thousand bushels hundred
and sixty acres on top of that we're Net
Zero as far as our energy use the
Renewable change my wife Carl and I both
decided on together and my wife is a big
part of our business and meeting our net
zero energy goals is something that we
decided together and we're both
committed to I first began looking into
renewable energy in the fall of two
thousand and one long and short of it
from 2001 it took me until 2009 to get
that windmill up a month after I put up
the windmill we installer for solar
system week
kind of add on to that as we needed more
power to all our cold storages shop
labor camp facilities here on the farm
including my house is powered with
renewable energy and that reduces our
carbon footprint on an annual basis we
produce about a hundred and eighty
thousand kilowatt hours of power so that
would be enough roughly the power 18
homes on an annual basis we look
worldwide there's not enough water and
energy and food is right up there we
live in a plentiful land here but you
look worldwide there's definite
shortages so those three things I think
there's always going to be a demand for
and because we're a growing business
we've created our own demand so why not
produce it and you utilize it I mean
really when you look at what we're doing
growing apples we're taking the energy
from the Sun and producing a crop of
apples so really what we're doing is the
same thing with the solar panels we're
harvesting the sunshine with apples or
renewable energy anything in life is a
gamble and anything new you're going to
take some lumps over and that's why you
know I ended up calling it the bleeding
edge instead of the leading edge because
you're gonna you're going to get some
cuts and scrapes and bruises when you're
trying out these new things but is there
an economic benefit to going netzero I
would say yes it's just you got to
manage your own timeline as far as the
repayment but it is a cost that you are
going to pay to the power company every
month for the rest of your life you
don't want it to be a burden to your
business but I think that there is a way
and we've proven that here that you can
have it both ways and I think we have an
obligation as farmers & for stewards of
the land to provide for the next
generation not just the next generation
of farmers but the next the next
generation through long-term planning
and careful management Chip and his
wife's orchard has become a local model
for renewable energy production so much
so that the community of Williamson New
York where the orchard is located has
embraced alternative energy at the
municipal level and committed itself to
going Net Zero it may not always be easy
but farmers like chip and dawn
found ways to reimagine the traditional
values of farming by incorporating new
technologies that promote their
businesses benefit their communities and
address climate change
you